>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Nicholas Alexander
Brown: Hi everyone.
My name is Nick Brown, I'm
a music specialist here
at the Library of Congress.
I work at the music division as
concert producer for our series
that takes place over
in Coolidge Auditorium.
Nice to see many friendly and
familiar faces, and also nice to see
so many new faces to our lecture
series here in the music division.
The talk today is going to be on boy
bands in the Library of Congress,
which is a topic that probably
hasn't been covered so much
in public events here but I
think it should be covered more.
The title is Hair Gel and
Groupies, which has nothing to do
with anything aside from
they're somewhat related topics
to boyband culture in terms of
there's a lot of hair gel going
on with musicians, as you'll
see in some of the photos.
And young tween groupies were
also a thing and continue
to be a thing with boy band culture.
So just a bit about the format
of what we're going to do today.
I'm going to kind of introduce a
thesis statement for you to ponder.
And then my goal is to kind
of introduce you to some
of the different types of materials
we have relative to boybands,
also introduce two different
kind of broad definitions
of what a boy band might be.
And then, hopefully have some
fun, and there's going to be a lot
of listening and viewing to be done.
For those that are watching this
webcast at some date in the future,
unfortunately the videos are
under copyright so I'm not going
to be able to include them in
the webcast version of this.
However, everything is on YouTube,
which is where I pulled them from.
And actually most of them are up
there legally which is kind of cool.
So if you can just go on YouTube
and search for the artist name
and the title and you'll
find the appropriate video.
Okay. So there are two
directions we can go
in with definitions for boy bands.
[Laughter] Oh, it gets better.
Well, geeze sorry.
Thank you James Wintle.
Any who, so there are two avenues
in which we can define boy bands;
the first sort of more commonly
used is referring to pop group --
male pop groups from the 90s
and into the 21st century
that particularly appealed
to young teen women,
which is a market segment of course.
And a broader definition of it.
Actually we'll go back and
retroactively apply boy bands
as a term to things -- to
entities like the Beetles or a lot
of the Motown bands are in groups
like The Temptations, the Four Tops.
And specifically with the 90s groups
we see a lineage that goes back
to the Jackson Five of course,
and some other folks
that we'll see in here.
There is an official Library
of Congress subject heading
for boy bands, which
is really awesome,
and there is also a Grove Music
Online article about boy bands,
which means it's so conservative
in mainstream society
that it's in Grove.
So also the Oxford Dictionaries
have it listed as quote,
"a pop group composed of
attractive young men whose music
and image are designed
to appeal primarily
to a young teenage audience."
And there you can see the
record for the Library
of Congress subject
heading of "boy bands,"
and then this is the visualization
of the subject heading,
so you can see a broader
scope would be vocal groups.
I do want to mention that I'm
mainly a classical music guy,
but I grew up listening to all
this 90s boy band pop stuff,
even though I was not a
teenage girl, so what that says
about the stereotype I don't know.
Since the Library of Congress
started accepting copyrights
in the 19th Century --
well in the 19th Century --
and we also had some going
back earlier than that,
the institution has been
a repository for American
and global cultural memory.
And whether or not we like it boy
band culture is a part of history.
And there [are] a lot of folks in
mainstream musicological circles
who think there is no merit in
studying popular music culture,
and that is nonsense if you ask me,
and they need to broaden
their horizons a little bit.
It doesn't mean that they need to
study pop music but someone should,
and therefore it is the Library
of Congress' duty to collect
and preserve items relevant to
important trends in history,
particularly American history.
So there's a very important
dependence on places like Library
of Congress as a repository
institution,
and also comparable institutions
like the Grammy Museum,
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame, also
various centers for popular music
and popular culture studies that
exist at various universities.
All of these folks are working to
make content available to those
that want to study
it, which is great.
Here's that Oxford Music Online
article, it's under copyright
so I just gave you a little snippet,
and is by a guy named Craig Jenix
who also wrote the entries
for most of the boy bands
who are actually listed in Oxford
Music Online, which is cool.
And his article is
quite entertaining,
I'll give you a little excerpt here.
There's several different key
ingredients to the boy band concept.
Right? So there's some
kind of sex appeal
for young women, and also young men.
And there is a certain
kind of conflict
because these boy bands are
appealing to teenage girls
who are not 18, so there has to be
a very PG rated of appeal going on,
which is tricky and I'm
sure someone can study that.
There's also certain involvement
with dance as you can see
with Backstreet Boys or Nsync.
Music videos and the dance that went
into productions has a huge role
and is probably more
impressive or more entertaining
than the music in many cases.
So going back to Craig Jenix's
description here, I'll share a quote
with you which is kind of funny.
So "despite the frequent use
of subtle sexual euphemisms they
typically emphasize the emotional
connection over physical, making
the genre culturally appropriate
for adolescent participation.
They presented their lyrics
through uncomplicated harmonies,
which is probably the most positive
way that's ever been described,
and accessible song structures."
So he kind of puts forth
this structure and this model
for boy bands which I think we
can go back and apply to any
of the bands we're going
to talk about today,
in that the boy bands
were representative
of the different archetypes in sort
of young man, young male culture.
So there's the jock.
He also uses clown, the
rebel, the heartthrob,
and the hot mess pretty
much -- I added that one in.
You can see in, I think
it's Backstreet Boys,
the guy with dreads.
That's not a good thing.
So why do we collect and
preserve these materials?
I gave a bit of an intro,
but for anyone who likes
to criticize my interest in
this I point you to the mission
of the Library of Congress,
which says,
"The library's essential
mission is to provide Congress
and then the federal government and
the American people with a rich,
diverse, and enduring
source of knowledge.
That can be relied upon to
inform, inspire, and engage them,
and support their intellectual
and creative endeavors."
And this is the cover of
the new strategic plan
for anyone who hasn't seen it yet.
There's some other bits within
the strategic plan that kind
of give us the justification
for doing this work,
including "The Library of Congress
is a chief steward of America's
and the world's record of
knowledge and is a springboard
to the future while providing
indispensable services to Congress."
Now, Congress probably isn't going
to come borrowing a One Direction
book but some of you staffers might,
and there is certainly a
need to have an understanding
of performing arts copyright
-- things like recordings,
and sheet music, and such, and these
materials can serve as a resource
for that, especially in terms
of figuring out who owns what.
And there are some
lawsuits going on,
which we'll talk about
in a little while.
There are some values that are
pointed out in the strategic plan
that I'd also like to mention.
Excerpts from the values are "...to
leverage the strength of diversity
in the library staff,
collections, and constituents."
Certainly there is diversity
if we bring in pop culture
with highbrow intellectual
culture such as art music.
And also, in the core functions of
the Library of Congress, "Acquire,
describe, make accessible, secure
and preserve a universal collection
of knowledge in physical
and electronic formats.
And obtain electronic
access for its own users
to digital materials
held by other entities."
And then, a second core function:
"Demonstrate the scope and value
of library collection, staff
expertise, and resulting scholarship
through a variety of public
programs, such as this one,
publications and online
presentations."
So there is a -- an important
figure who I'd like to mention
and this is probably the first time
he's being mentioned in relationship
to 90s pop bands, Oscar
Sonneck, who as the second chief
of the music division
really instilled this vision
of the Music Division collections
being the national performing arts
and music resource for study,
so a shout out to Oscar Sonneck.
And one thing that was
part of his vision was
to "Create a musical
collection worthy
of America's national library,"
and also, "The development
of a collection reflecting
musical culture."
There is no value judgement placed
in that statement, so ponder that.
There's some other reasons why
I think boybands are worthy
of our attention somewhat.
They give a lot of context to
major issues happening in history.
And as you'll see in some of
the materials that we'll look
at you can see fashion as it was
evolving from the 80s into 90s,
which some people argue is in
response to economic conditions
in the US and globally, post
Reagan, during Reagan, et cetera,
and conflict with the Gulf War for
example if anyone saw the movie
"In the Army Now," which is also
probably the first time it's ever
been mentioned at the
Library of Congress.
A lot of the fashion statements made
in a film like that are reflected
in the images that you'll see
related to the pop bands here.
Also if we look back
at larger scale topics
like the Civil Rights Movement,
there's major roles for music
and pop music in those topics.
And the boy bands, whether we like
it or not, are part of the culture.
So let's keep looking at it.
So getting a little further into
this, there are three main areas
where we get our boy band
materials from, and this applies
to pretty much any
other kind of material.
So copyright deposits,
which we mentioned earlier,
there are also the
donations of materials,
and then acquisitions
of special collections.
We'll see in the images today,
and also the show and tell
that you can see in the
end that there are --
most of the things you're going to
see are copyright deposit materials.
But there [are] also situations
of boy bands being incorporated
into things like public
broadcasting news coverage,
in which case you can go into the
new archive of public broadcasting
to get more information and see
how the media is covering that.
So hey, look at that --
it's reception history of boy
bands in public news making.
So some of the types of materials
we'll address are non-fiction books,
sheet music, memorabilia,
periodicals and newspapers,
also I'll add serials to
that list, audio recordings,
and film and TV materials.
So I'll kind of explain some
of the different materials
as we go through here.
This is a shelf in the music 420s --
ML 420s, where there [are] a
whole ton of Beatles books,
which I just discovered
for the first time
because I generally
don't go to that section.
But I went there now
and it was great.
There's a lot more about
the Beatles than a lot
of other really important
classical composers
who we pay much more attention to.
So that is certainly a reflection
of popular culture creating
content related to popular music
that then [inaudible] -- so
there's more attention paid
by popular culture than
academia is my point there;
and you can see the result of this.
And a lot of these
books are -- there's --
it's kind of biographical
sketches of them.
There's also some strange
memorabilia books, like The Beatles
Down Under, which is a
title here you can see
in the orange on the left.
And then, there's also scholarly
publications related to the Beatles.
There's the complete
Idiot's Guide to The Beatles,
The Cambridge Companion
to the Beatles (which
if anyone's a classical music
scholar, the Cambridge companions
to composers are really great),
The Beatle's Encyclopedia,
The Beatles 365 Days -- this is like
a good coffee table book of photos,
and then we'll get into
the Jackson Five here.
So we all know the Jackson Five?
Does anyone not know who
the Jackson Five are?
Okay. Cool.
So just for the inter-webs
world this was
where Michael Jackson got his start,
it was a boy band formed in 1969
under the auspices
of Motown Records,
and they were modeled
after the Temptations.
This is an example of an
item in the collections.
This is a video recording that
came through copyright deposit
of a Soul Train episode that
featured the Jackson Five,
and we will get to watch it.
Okay. So that's an example of
something that's a video format.
Right? If we're going to keep
in mind the topic of fashion,
notice what they were wearing;
bell bottoms, really tight,
the hairdos were important.
There's also certain dance
style reflected in the music,
and also note how they're very --
at least in that little
clip that we saw, --
focused behind the microphones.
They're not running all around
as might have been the case
in other videos.
This is an item that
you can see over here,
which is in that M421
world -- ML421, sorry.
And it is a Michael
Jackson scrapbook,
so it is specifically
looking at his development
in the early years
of the Jackson Five.
Some cool photos.
And just for you, over 100
never before seen photos
of Michael and his family.
Does anyone know what this is?
Okay. Well yeah.
It's sheet music.
So we have a lot of marching
band scores, totally random
but we're the repository for
copyright, so we're the place
that would have them aside
from performing arts
library that does band music.
What's interesting is if you look
at the marching band music there's
a certain level of repertoire
that gets into that world.
So you'll see here two of
the Jackson Five songs.
I'm sure these things exist
but the Backstreet Boy
and Nsync marching band arrangements
have yet to be found by me
in our collections, and
that might be a result
of the arrangers just
not submitting them.
But I can say somehow
there's a greater value
to the Jackson Five
artistically than Backstreet Boys,
which I don't know that
anyone would disagree with.
And just to give you another
taste of Jackson Five.
Cool. So we're seeing changes in
costuming, even from 1970 to 1971.
This is of course not a
large enough sample size
to determine something definitive,
but you can see there's a lot
more dancing going on at least
with Michael Jackson in this case.
And the white pants with
the Christmas tree is --
are interesting.
Okay. So going to shift over
to the Latin American world now
with a pop boy band called Menudo.
Woo. [Laughter] I don't
think I was born
yet when they were
a thing, I'm sorry.
[Laughter] It's okay.
So Menudo originally formed in 1977,
they were based out of Puerto Rico.
And one funny fact about their
band was that the singers used
to originally get kicked out when
they turned 16, because I guess
that was the barrier in
terms of the PG-ness.
There's a funny term used by
the writer in Grove Music Online
about them called Menudo-Mania
in terms of the hype around them,
they became more popular in
the United State in the 80s.
And over time there were 30
plus singers on their stage,
not at the same time, but they
kind of rotated in and out
because of that age limit.
So here you see a kind of, you know,
juvenile memorabilia book
from 1984 about them.
One thing that I do have to say
about the library's collections
with regard to boy bands is that
non-US based boy bands are not
as represented in our
collections, for various reasons,
just like all kinds
of other topics--
in terms of if you go in
and look at Menudo compared
to Backstreet Boys there's
like 2000 times more content
for Backstreet Boys.
And the place where there is more of
the Latin American boy band music is
in the copyright deposits
of sound recordings.
And I think that there's a lot
work that we can do in terms of,
you know, if we find people
who have private collections
of Menudo memorabilia for
example and there's a division
in the library that is
interested in growing that area
of collections then it, you
know, maybe that's a good thing
to look into, but I'm not a manager
so I don't have any
say, that's okay.
Here you can see one of
those musical recordings.
Interesting thing about RCA
Victor, does anyone know the story
about Carl Engel and bringing
in Victor Talking recordings
back in the 20s?
Does anyone know who Carl Engel was?
No music division people can answer?
So Carl Engel was the third
chief of the music division.
He came into office in
1922 and lasted until 1934,
in which case he got a more powerful
job outside, I guess he saw it
that way; he went to become
president of G. Schirmer.
And when he came into the
music division he was all
about growing the collections
and fulfilling the mission
that Sonic had put in
place previous to him.
Engel developed a relationship with
the Victor Talking Record company --
Victor Talking Machine company.
And he kind of haggled them
for two years to get them
to donate recordings of commercial
releases and other unpublished stuff
to the library to develop
a sound collection.
And there was some wax cylinder
that existed somewhere before,
but in the literature that I've
found it said that Engel's project
with the Victor Company was really
the beginning of our sound archive
in the sense that we know today.
So over the course of
Engel's tenure they brought
in a few thousand recordings.
Some of those were selected
by Engel and his staff
from the Victor catalogues.
And later on, as the relationship
kind of weakened a bit,
the Victor Company
was just sending stuff
that they thought would
be worthwhile
for the music division
sound collections.
And nowadays there's a whole
recorded sound section as we know
and they have over 3.5
million recordings.
So it's kind of cool that the former
chief of the music division had
such an impact over time
starting from a little idea
and pestering of a
commercial entity.
Here you can see a little picture
of Menudo from a record cover
in 1982, note the attire.
And if we go back, note the
attire here, note the haircuts.
The mullet was in fashion, right?
I don't get the see through quality
of this though, that's
kind of weird.
This is a picture of
Menudo in New York City.
And I thank Kareliz Rodriguez
for sending it me today,
and it is from the Puerto
Rican digital library.
And this was taken in 1984
at Radio City Music Hall.
That's kind of cool,
they look happy.
Then here's another picture
from about 1977 or 1978,
there are all original Menudo
members in this picture,
and this is also from the
Puerto Rican Digital Library.
So now we've arrived at 1990.
Menudo, oh my gosh.
So the title of the album in the
song is No Me Corten El Pelo,
which means Don't Cut My Hair.
[Laughter] For anyone that
survived this era I think was --
you know, there was a
lot of long hair going
on with teenage rebellion with boys.
And -- yes.
And boys wearing headbands
and that kind of stuff.
So you can see that all, and there's
even the depiction of the scissors
with a do not cut symbol there.
And the record from the
collection here is of a VHS tape
of a performance of this album.
Cool. So you can keep watching
that on YouTube if you'd like.
It is not up there legally, so
we are adopting fair use for the
in person portion of this lecture,
and then [please] go Google it
if you want to watch it at home.
There are kind of weird
musical strands happening,
you could hear some throwbacks to,
like, 50s, early Elvis rock style.
And then, we get into much more
Latin beat dance feel going
on at this point, which one could
say speaks to the complicated
and close relationship
between Puerto Rican culture
and American culture,
or the differences
between those two cultures.
And just as a reminder,
that's what they used
to look like, quite a shock.
I think there's even eyeliner
on the guy in the bottom left.
Anyways, great.
So the next group I'd like to
talk about is called New Edition.
Does anyone remember them?
Yay. So funnily enough
they were also from Boston,
which is another group --
another group we're going to talk
about that's from Boston as well.
They were established in 1978
and the song we're going to check
out is called Candy Girl, which
was one of their top hits.
It's also the name this album here,
which was their main debut album.
They were big in the 80s and
some of the other big songs were
"Can You Stand in the Rain" and
"Cool It Now," and "Candy Girl" was
by a gentleman named Maurice
Star who also has a role in some
of the later bands
that we'll discuss.
And "Candy Girl" came in 1983.
Cool. So as you can see, they
filmed on location in Boston;
the Hatch Shell was there and
then, then the John Handcock tower.
And there were no windowpanes
falling down, oh well.
Cool. So the next group
that we're going to talk
about is the one you've
probably all been waiting for.
There they are New
Kids on the Block --
later NKOTB, later KNOTB BSB with
Backstreet Boys -- very strange.
I learned a lot, I'm telling you.
So they were formed in
1985 by Maurice Star,
who was the guy behind New Edition,
and there's Boston ties there.
The original band had Joey McIntyre,
Jorden Knight, Jonathan Knight,
Danny Wood, Donnie Walberg,
who some of you might know
from Blue Bloods, which
is on TV now.
It kind of went defunct in
1994, but they came back in 2011
for that CD recording
and also the tour
with the Backstreet Boys,
which is interesting.
And here you see just kind of
one of these memorabilia books.
This is called the "Only
Official Auto Biography
of America's Hottest Group, the
Inside Story Told in Their Words,"
and you can see it
over here for free.
So I have a kind of
interesting connection to them.
It's not anything substantive,
but this is a house
where the Knights lived.
Right. On Melville Ave.
in Boston is the just --
the street that runs down the side
of the Dorchester district court
and I lived there -- not in a house
but down the street for, like,
two years when I was
a kid growing up.
It just - [was] actually at
the time when they sold it.
And their mom sold it to
the Salvation Army in 1996,
and now it is a sort of a
multi-purpose community outreach
and residential facility.
And apparently there are people
that do New Kids on the Block, like,
fan tours in Boston and there
are five sites that they, like,
go around, take pictures at.
And they're all middle aged women
who do it, that's kind of funny.
Anyways, so this is a kind
of interesting New Kids
on the Block related item.
It is a book as you can see, and
the title is New Kids on the Block;
Oral Histories of Immigrant Teens.
And it was published by
Scholastic I believe,
and you can see it over here.
And it's the idea to kind of
portray their immigrant roots
in a positive happy
manner to youth and such.
Teenage immigrants from various
countries recount the emotional
experience of fleeing their
homelands and adjusting
to a new life in the United States.
This is the photo you probably
saw in the event flyer.
This is a juvenile
book about New Kids
on the Block, it came out in 1991.
This resides in the ML3930
world where you can see stuff
from juvenile books about Leonard
Bernstein to One Direction,
which you'll see over there, and
New Kids on the Block and the like.
The Menudo book is
also from this section.
Step By Step, one of their big hits.
This a recording of that
by CBS Records in 1990,
you can still see Maurice
Star was producing.
And now you'll get to hear it.
Okay. Luckily these songs are
so repetitive you don't need
to listen to more than a minute.
[Laughter]
Okay. So to get into
periodical and newspaper realm,
did you know there are
comic books about boy bands?
I didn't know that.
I thought it was totally wild.
I used to read Calvin and Hobbes and
Spiderman, but apparently New Kids
on the Block was a thing to read.
And here you can see several comic
book records related to New Kids
on the Block in the newspaper and
current periodical reading room.
The titles are, Hanging Tough, Comic
Tour, Chillin', Backstage Pass,
and just New Kids on the Block.
And here you can see Chillin'.
Another way of describing these
comic books apparently is calling
them a digest magazine, because
they were clearly propaganda items
for the band and not about
making a big creative statement
for the comic book industry.
This is another example, going
back to the film video collections,
an episode of "VH1 Behind The
Music," which I'm sure some
of you used to watch or still watch
if it exists still, I don't know.
I was more of an MTV guy, sorry.
And this was actually from when --
from 2008, it was kind
of a reunion attempt.
There was a Richie Rich New Kids on
the Block comic book, and we have it
because no one else does.
And because the boy bands are
commercial successes generally,
if you make it to these
groups' level,
once they break apart there's
always avenues for reuniting,
which happened when
New Kids on the Block
and Backstreet Boys
did their tour in 2011.
And then, also some of the folks
go off in their own directions,
like Jorden Knight, who did a
whole remix album of New Kids
on the Block songs, which we have
because no one else bought it.
[Laughter]
And this is a picture from
him performing in that tour
with the Back Street Boys.
And there is the official
publicity for NKOTBSB.
And we have that recording.
Kind of seems like an attempt to get
people who grew up during New Kids
on the Block era and their children
who grew up in Backstreet Boys era
to listen to the same thing.
This is an example of sort of
a pop culture book that we have
in the music division's collections,
it's called, Boyz and the Bandz,
the hottest men in music from Elvis
to Nsync universe,
and Donald F Rider.
I guess was the author.
[Inaudible] [Laughter]
In the bottom left.
So this is an example of a kind
of literature, even if it's kind
of memorabilia fan books existing to
kind of bring this topic together,
even though this is a little
broader, but it kind of refers
to that sex appeal topic.
Boyz II Men, another great boy band.
They are probably one of the more
functional reunion type groups.
They're still touring and as we
all know hopefully, they performed
in the Gershwin Prize
in 2014 with Billy Joel.
This is again from that juvenile
section 3930, and the book is
over here for you to see.
Note their fashion
choices down there, 1997.
Less overalls, shorter
hair, more buttoned up.
It looks like they're at
an awards show though,
so that might explain it.
Cool. And just a funny story, he
forgot his cufflinks that night
and he borrowed mine, just
kind of [a] good story.
This is an example of a choral
octavo score of an arrangement
of pop music: a Boyz II
Men song, "Water Runs Dry,"
written by Babyface -- and it's
also available in TTBB and SAB
if anyone's interested
in purchasing them.
This is probably one
of the better avenues
for sheet music revenue I would say.
Since, you know, high school choirs
all over the country might want
to perform current pop songs.
And there's a market, so of course
we would hope these would exist
with copyright permission from
the original copyright holder.
All right.
Switching to another
Latin group, Chamos,
which was a Venezuelan group.
And here is a record for one of
their reunion recordings from 2008.
This is a group that probably
didn't want to reunite,
and you'll see why in a moment.
It's kind of funny, but let's see.
This group was much less
influential than Menudo
and they didn't last quite as
long, but it gives you a sense of,
you know, things that were
trendy in other parts of the US
and Latin America trickling
down to South America as well.
That's about all I
can handle, sorry.
It's fun, I was having a ball
in the office this morning.
So this is a song called
"Siempre te amaré,"
which is "I'll Always Love You."
Now for the reunion video.
It's an example of pop stars aging.
So anyways I think that was pulled
from like a daytime talk show thing,
which has a certain
audience and demographic.
Did in anyone in here
buy that reunion CD?
No? Okay. Okay.
So a little known secret
to all of the 90s
and early-21st century boy band
and sort of mainstream pop music is
that most of it was
written by one guy.
And this is him, his name is
Max Martin, he was born in 1971.
So he wrote hits for folks like
Britney Spears, the Backstreet Boys,
Nsync, Kelly Clarkson, Pink, Katy
Perry, Glee, T-Swift, AKA Tay,
AKA Taylor Swift -- who we
like because she gives money
to classical music organizations
[like the] Seattle Symphony
and then the Nashville
Symphony in particular.
So some of the specific songs with
him include, "I Want It That Way,"
"Oops I Did It Again,"
"You Drive Me Crazy,"
"You Hit Me Baby One More
Time," [and] "California Girls."
He has had I believe it was
over 21 number one hits,
which has only been topped by Paul
McCartney and one other person.
And all told he has about
58 plus songs that made it
to the top ten charts
of the Billboard charts.
So I think he's making lot more
money than all of these other people
if he held onto his copyright.
So segue to the Backstreet Boys.
Yay! This was my favorite boy
band when I was growing up.
They were established in 1993,
originally in Orlando Florida.
The first -- the original
members were Nick Carter, Howie --
I don't know how to
pronounce that, sorry.
Brian Latrell, A.J. McLean,
and Kevin Richardson.
They've now sold over
130 million records,
and some folks call them
the most successful boy band
of all time as a result of that.
They have some legal troubles
going on with their management,
and it's been a problem
I guess for several years
where management wasn't giving them
what they thought they were entitled
to in terms of performance fees
and royalties and kind of business.
Sadly, not uncommon.
So this is an example of, you know,
not the most valuable
intellectual book.
It is a Backstreet Boys quiz
book, which you can glance
at over there if you would like.
This is an official Backstreet
Boys book from the 421 world.
You can see, well, Nick
Carter's hair didn't change much.
I was hoping it had.
And this is a MARC record
of "I Want It That Way."
Who knew? So you can see
here that we got this --
I think this was a music video.
Yes. And it came in
through copyright,
you can see there the copyright
classification number and such.
And here's the video.
So my funny story with the
Backstreet Boys and that song is
in sixth grade we had to do a
project where we took a pop song
and talked about ancient China
history and re-did the lyrics.
So my song was called
the China Stomp
and it was set to I
Want It That Way.
That's kind of funny.
But anyway, so this is kind of one
of the quirkier little
memorabilia books
that we have, it's about yea big.
And if you look at the table
it's actually standing up,
it's the only item standing up.
Back in the day when we had Borders
and actual plentiful huge bookstores
around there were often those
little tiny kitschy books
at the checkout counter, so
that's that kind of concept.
We also had the one
for Nsync, don't worry.
It's kind of like the
Schoenberg, Stravinsky things,
Nsync or Backstreet Boys, sorry.
Pick sides.
So -- and believe it or not
we also have karaoke CDs.
Yay! So this is the karaoke CD from
1999 that included Backstreet Boys'
"I'll Never Break Your
Heart," and sorts of things
that are beyond what
you would expect.
We have things like episodes of
Larry King Live in the collections,
and the Backstreet Boys
appeared on Larry King Live.
So someone could come up
with a paper on that somehow.
What's interesting though is it's a
reunion kind of performance in 2001,
so that comes with
interesting things.
Also does anyone remember
Now That's What I call Music?
Apparently they're
up to, like, 40 plus
or 50 plus now, which is insane.
But Now That's What I Call
Music 2 came out in 1999
and it included Backstreet Boys, and
you can see some of the other groups
on here, Brittany Spears,
Sheryl Crow,
Fat Boy slim, JayZ, U2, et cetera.
And for those that don't know these,
they are kind of compilation CDs
of the top hits every so often,
and there were many ads for these
on MTV and VH1 back in the day.
So Nsync, many of us know them.
Here's another quiz
book, very exciting.
So this is my favorite
item that I've found --
there's a CD-Rom software slash
game called the Nsync Hotline
and we have it, and this is
a little screenshot from it.
And what was interesting
about this game is
that there was a fantasy phone and
game controller which you would plug
into your computer so
that you could then speak
to the members of the band.
And the software had
little responses programmed
in so you could interact with them.
Yeah, and it's under
juvenile software.
There are fantastic fold
out photos in this book.
Oh, and there are the dreads on
the second guy from the left.
Cool. This is just kind of an iconic
photo that describes I think a lot
of people's childhood in the 90s --
if you were coming of age when Nsync
and Backstreet Boys were big.
And this is of course "No Strings
Attached," you get the joke.
Oh, this was also gym pants time.
I don't know if these are leather
or not, but gym pants were a thing
and people wore them all
time, pre-yoga pants.
And the little -- if you
see the guy on the left --
the zipper on the bottom so
that you could open up the legs.
And just for kicks, "Bye Bye Bye."
Cool. We're nearing
the end, don't worry.
Okay. Here's an example of
piano vocal guitar sheet music
for "Tearin' Up My Heart,"
one of Nsync's hits that's
in our collections, M1630.2.
This is the One Direction section
of a shelf in the 3930s I think.
There's a lot more One Direction
than most other boy bands
and I don't know why that is,
maybe they just have a
good marketing person.
This is the very One
Direction [item]
that sparked my whole
interest in this topic,
because I thought it was cool
and very out of place in the rows
and rows of classical music shelves.
We'll give you a little
taste of One Direction.
You get it.
So interesting things
about One Direction.
They were originally
solo auditionees
on the X-Factor UK the TV show.
And then Simon Cowell
kind of decided
that they would make some money
if they were singing together.
So they reentered the X-Factor as
an ensemble and placed third place.
And after that point it was
about 2012 when they exploded
in the international
scene, and since then one
of the guys has departed and
there's drama and apparently he --
I think today his new
solo thing charted ahead
of the One Direction stuff.
Anyways so -- that just
appeared in my Facebook feed,
I didn't go seeking
it out, I promise.
So this is some more of the One
Direction goodies that we have.
Some more of the -- fan book.
You can see again hairstyles
have changed since the 'fro era.
We're going to skip that one.
Cool. So we have arrived at the end.
I want to just kind of remind
you of some resources if you'd
like to get further into
pop music studies here
at the library or boy band studies.
Catalog.loc.gov -- our
online catalogue --
is a great place to start.
If you have trouble there
ask a reference specialist
in the music division or
recorded sound section,
et cetera; they are your friends.
For example, I learned from one
colleague that we don't have much
of the pop music copyright deposits
because there was a certain point
when the legislation changed and
recordings were able to be submitted
to cover all of the copyright.
So for example, with Mr. Martin,
who composed all of those songs
for Backstreet Boys, Nsync, et
cetera, we only have a handful
of his songs of all of those
20 something number ones
and 50 something top ten in
terms of sheet music form.
But we do have all the
recordings for sure.
There is a popular music
encyclopedia that we have available
in the music division's
performing art's reading room,
and that is a reference item
that you can use in there.
This is the entry for New Kids on
the Block in that encyclopedia.
We also have various pop
music serials and journals
that address these topics
in a scholarly level --
or in a scholarly manner.
This is another journal here
called "Popular Music and Society."
We have Billboard magazines,
so if you want to see
from the horse's mouth who did
what at what point in terms
of charting you can check that out.
Seventeen magazine -- we
have that in our collections.
I didn't know that
until I looked this up.
But if we're thinking about the
way that boy bands are marketed
to teenage women and
young women an item
like Seventeen magazine is a
source of seeing, you know,
what was being done in marketing.
So if you're a marketer
for, you know,
the music business there's some
value in that kind of a material.
These are commemorative
covers, so you can collect all
of the One Direction members.
And for the academics who like
to hate, The Learned Society
for Musicology has a popular
music study group, and the purpose
of that study group is to advocate
for popular music resources
and scholarship, and also to
raise awareness about the fact
that this is a legitimate
scholarly pursuit.
And I think in certainly musicology
worlds there are more jobs perhaps
coming open for people who are
doing things like ethnomusicology
and pop music studies than
another Bach specialist,
because a lot of those Bach
specialists exist and hold
onto those jobs until they
don't want them anymore.
So a bunch of thank you's.
Thanks to the music division for
allowing me to do this curator talk,
I really enjoyed putting it together
and sharing some kind of quirky bits
from our collections with you.
Thanks to Sue Vita and Jan
Lauridsen for allowing us to these.
Also Hispanic Cultural Society and
LC-Globe for supporting my work
and also helping getting the
word out about this event
and all of our curator talks.
Also Carl Engel for kind of
changing the culture and bringing
in recordings in the 1920s.
That's a huge deal and our
collections are so rich
because of the recordings
that we have.
And also, Backstreet Boys just
for being fun and entertaining.
And that's it, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov